and then the unthinkable happen knowing
that Beijing control enough votes in the
Legislative Council protesters
surrounded the complex earlier in the
morning successfully preventing
lawmakers from convening I was then
serving my first jail sentence for a
moment I wonder why the news channel was
replaying footage of the umbrella
movement although it was not long before
I realized Hong collar work back with
even stronger determination Lam saucepan
the bill on June 15 but fell short of
fully withdrawing it a historical two
million people demonstrate the following
day equivalent to one in four out of our
entire population I'm not aware of
anything comparable to this level of
this content again government in more
than history I was released
exactly three months ago on June 17 and
have since John fellow Hong Kong as the
protest in the most creative ways
possible
in addition to the bill withdrawn with
the man Lam to retract label on us as
riotous job or political charges and
conduct an independent investigation
into a police brutality
some of us crowdfunded for newspaper
advertisement ahead of the g20 summit in
late June calling for the world not to
leak at Hong Kong other entered the
chamber of Legislative Council complex
on July 1st the same day another half
million Hong Kong's protest peacefully
crowd continue to show up in large
lumber in the past 15 week ends with
more rallies taking place almost daily
across the thérèse but the government
would not listen
instead of defusing the political crisis
is dramatically empowered the riot
police the movement enriched a training
pond on 21 of July that night
pro-beijing Fox with suspect ties to
organized crime Gator in the Yunnan
train station and in this train a deadly
attack not just protester returning home
reporters on the scene but even
passers-by
the police refuse to show up despite
repeat emergency call plucking Hong Kong
into a police state with more violence
on August 5th alone the day Hong Kong is
participate in a general strike
riot police should 800 canister of tear
gas to disperse the peaceful mass
compare that to your only 87 fire in the
entire umbrella movement five years ago
the police excessive force today is
clear the excessive use of pepper spray
pepper balls rubber bullets been back
runs and what cannons almost all of
which are imported from Western
democracy and no less troubling in light
of this I applaud chairman McGovern and
congressman Smith for introducing the
protect Hong Kong act last week
Americans company must not profit from
the Fowler's crackdown of freedom-loving
Hong Kong's co-chairman Rubio is also
right for recently writing that Hong
Kong special status under American law
depends on the city being treated as a
separate customs area Beijing should not
have it both ways
wrapping all the economic benefit of
Hong Kong standing in the world while
erosion of our freedom this is the most
important reason why the Hong Kong human
rights and democracy Act enjoys the
boats approach of Hong Kong civil
society Lemm finally withdraw the bill
earlier this month but just as protester
have long stopped calling for her
resignation
this decision was almost meaningless by
now the movement is far from over
because it has long move beyond one bill
or one person our most important demand
is general structural change in Hong
Kong which means free election our
government's lack of representation lies
at the heart of the matter
as I speak Hong Kong is then at a
critical juncture the snake have never
been higher we are confronted by the
huge Chinese military buildup just
across the border in Shenzhen President
Xi Jingping is unlikely to
like action before the upcoming national
day in October but no one can be sure
what's next sending in the tanks remain
irrational but not impossible with
Chinese interference in Taiwan Tibet and
especially Xin Jiang it served as a
reminder that Beijing is prepared to go
far in pursuit of it grand imperial
project I was once the face of Hong
Kong's youth activism in this leaderless
movement my sacrifice are minimal
compared to those among us who have been
layoffs of protesting who have been
injured but you afraid of even going to
a hospital or who have been forced to
take their own life to have each lots
and ice the youngest of the 1,500
arrested so far is only 12 years old
school boy I don't know them personally
yes that thing is my pain we belong to
the same community struggling for our
rights of self-determination so we can
build one Prater and common future
a child born today will not even have
celebrate his or her 28th birthday by
2047 when the 50 years unchanged policy
is set to expire that deadline is closer
to us that it appears there's no return
for us that case from now when historian
look back I'm sure that 2019 will turn
out to have been a watershed I hope the
historians will celebrate the United
States Congress for having stood on the
side of Hong Kong as the style of human
rights and democracy goes brass honghong
thank you
miss Howe welcome Thank You chairman
McGovern co-chair Monroe Bo and the
members of this commission for holding
this hearing and for having us here at
this very critical moment for Hong Kong
for more than 100 days now young people
in Hong Kong have been at the forefront
of our resistance this is a leaderless
movement with widespread participation
from people of all walks of life it is a
fight for democracy a fight for human
rights and most of all a fight for
universal values what started in June as
a 1 million people march has morphed
into a struggle for fundamental
political reform in Hong Kong chief
executive Kerry lamps misjudgments and
arrogance worsen the situation
resulting in a total clampdown of the
Beijing government over Hong Kong's
affairs to date more than 1,500 Hong
Kong is the youngest at the age of 12
years old have been unreasonably
arrested sadly it has become a daily
occurrence to see youngsters being
pinned to the ground with had
concussions of not being knocked
unconscious on the other hand riot
police and plainclothes officers have
since early on deliberately hidden their
ID numbers and warrant cuts making it
impossible for us to even certify their
legitimacy let alone hold them
accountable on August 21st police from
the special tactical unit charged into
Prince Edward MTR station beating up
passengers randomly they then shut down
the station for 24 hours refusing
medical care for those who were injured
raising even suspicions of possible
deaths in the station separately now
they will be charging in sanguinary
schoolyards shopping malls and buses
where young people merely dressed in
black can be searched or even arrested
without justification in other words
merely being young is a crime in the
police state of Hong Kong the protests
began with an extradition bill but at
the core it has always been about these
no conflicts between two very different
set of values on one hand the China
model which has no respect over human
rights and the rule of law and our
hybrid City that has enjoyed these very
freedoms for the most of its existence
with a deep attachment to these
universal values that the United States
and other Western societies treasured
Hong Kong represents something unique in
the world
we have long held dear our rule of law
transparent institutions and the freedom
of expression in a part of the world
where these are most often threatened
then upheld however this system is now
under great threat companies like Hong
Kong's major airline Cathay Pacific has
succumbed to political pressure firing
dozens of employees due to their
political stance the business community
community is coerced into making
political decisions as a singer and
activist from Hong Kong I have
experienced the suppression firsthand
ever since the umbrella movement in 2014
I have been blacklisted by the communist
government my songs and my name are
censored on Chinese internet pressured
by the Chinese government sponsors have
pulled out even international brands
have kept their distances for the past
five years and even more so recently
China tried to smear and silenced me
with their propaganda machines spreading
false claims right now I am facing
threats from pro-beijing supporters and
could face arrest and prosecution at any
time not only if I face difficulties in
both China and Hong Kong but the
self-censorship has now spread towards
global institutions and cities recently
the National Gallery of Victoria and
Melbourne Australia denied venue to an
event of Chinese artists Peduto and
myself due to security concerns
celebrities from Hong Kong Taiwan and
China are all pressured into voicing
their unanimous support for the Beijing
government and could be condemned for
keeping their silence Hong Kong s are
now living in a constant fear and have
unfortunately lost most of our freedoms
for City that has been famously known as
politically indifferent the younger
generations have took up
the road to safeguard our home standing
up courageously to the corrupted system
in spite of increased suppression to the
rest of the world the United States is
often a symbol of freedom and democracy
the freedom Americans enjoy is something
that the people of Hong Kong have long
hoped for even though our languages and
cultures defer what we have in common is
the pursuit for justice freedom and
democracy through the challenges of Hong
Kong the West is also waking up to the
China to China's insinuating power in a
global scale Hong Kong is connected to
the world in multiple ways but China is
trying to isolate it to exert control if
Hong Kong Falls it would easily become
the springboard for the totalitarian
regime of China to push its rules and
priorities overseas utilizing its
economic economic powers to conform
others to their communist values just as
they have done with Hong Kong in the
past 22 years the US and its allies have
everything to fear if they wish to
maintain a world that is free open and
civil I therefore urge the US Congress
to stand by Hong Kong and most of all to
pass the Hong Kong human rights and
democracy Act this is not a plea for the
so called foreign interference this is a
plea for democracy this is a plea for
the freedom to choose and lastly I would
like to quote Eleanor Roosevelt your
most beloved first lady you gained
strength courage and confidence by every
experience in which you really stopped
to look fear in the face you are able to
say to yourself I lived through this
horror I can take the next thing that
comes along this is a global fight for
the universal values that we all cherish
and Hong Kong is in the very front lines
of this fight we are once fearful of
what might have come with our silence
and for that we have now become fearless
thank you
Thank You mr. John welcome chairman
McCullen Kojima whoopee oh and members
of the committee thank you for your
invitation to this hearing last year
Chinese President Xi Jinping sat in a
closed-door meeting that China would
never embrace the traditional
independence in the rest this is why
people in Hong Kong are trying hard to
reject the extradition bill because we
do not believe in a country who not
stand on human rights disqualifying our
legislators and kidnapping our
booksellers we want to protect our legal
system as the last barrier against
Beijing's political interference
apart from asking for the withdrawal of
the bill Hong Kong people also demand
for an investigation into police
brutality to save Hong Kong from turning
into a police state more importantly we
demand for the universal suffrage
we deeply believe that without any
structural political reform and it
governments chosen by the people there
is no possibility for Hong Kong to
restore prosperity we cannot have a
society compromise in the interests of
individuals the voice of these people
should always be heard unfortunately our
governments ignores our demands by
saying that we have no stake in the
society our student union members are
detained followed beaten and threatened
during the detain the detainment one of
our student union members were told by
the police that it was reasonable for
them to wait some female protester when
they frequently work overtime
besides the authority tries to stop us
for having peaceful huh strike where
more than fifty thousand students
participating in it
people who side with Beijing and now
advocating to install civilians cameras
inside the classroom to monitor teachers
and students to who dare to support a
strike and support the movement this
apparently violates our academic freedom
and freedom of speech this is the rice
terror
created by the Beijing government
which should be alerted by all people
here nowadays students and Hong Kong
people are even ready to die for Hong
Kong and some already did they believe
that the only limits to their freedom is
their death this is the ultimate
sacrifice for the motherland and we must
not forget them many students face
strong abstraction from their family
some of them are even for stood to live
home but stay still choose to head to
the front line carrying a letter with
their last will they are determined they
understand that the price of freedom is
high it always has been but it is a
price they are willing to pay and it is
a path of liberation they are willing to
choose we do not fight for freedom out
of passion passion will burn out we
fight for freedom from a sense of duty
and dignity
China is rising China is using his
nationalism and invasive economic
dominance
to colonize small countries and put
intense pressure on people and companies
like heavy Pacific who do not conform to
them teachers students civil servants
businessman are all facing political
perch in Hong Kong this new form of
imperialism of China poses a severe
threat to Hong Kong this is a crisis of
values and system we need to contain the
Communist Party of China all the way up
to Hong Kong is the primary moved to
contain China one country to system will
aspire in 2047 US government's should
help Hong Kong people have the right to
decide our future therefore we urge the
US Congress to pass the human rights and
democracy Act to expand the spirit
ascension list to all individuals who
didn't finish our human rights moreover
if a general universe universal suffrage
cannot be achieved immediately our
autonomy and war flow will continue to
erode the situation of China
manipulating Hong Kong as a backdoor for
trading with Iran and North Korea will
also continue then the US government
should not aknowledge the special status
of Hong Kong us must send a strong
signal that this special status should
be canceled
if Hong Kong lost is autonomy in order
to put pressure on China otherwise China
will keep taking advantage of Hong
Kong's as an International Society that
hollow out our liberal values there's
such an
you
to fight for democracy and freedom as
well as Thomas Jefferson once said that
he would be for ever for against any
form of tyranny and I believe this a
time for Emmer Americans to stand with
Hong Kong well for Hong Kong sit are
coming thank you thank you this home
welcome Thank You chairman McGovern
co-chair Rubio and members of the
Commission thank you for this
opportunity it's an honor for me to
stand in solidarity with the frontline
activist I want to thank the commission
members for their critical support for
the Hong Kong people and your leadership
on the Hong Kong human rights and
democracy Act and the protect hong kong
act over the past three months the whole
world has witnessed the historic david
and goliath standoff and against all
odds the Hong Kong people are standing
up to the powerful authoritarian regime
in Beijing in this historic battle they
are not only fighting for the Democratic
future of 7.4 million Hong Kong people
but they're holding the regional and
global frontline on preserving human
dignity and rights for all people as
congressman McGovern has already
mentioned the past summer of discontent
is in fact part of years of ongoing
resistance by the Hong Kong people
against Beijing's encroachment on Hong
Kong's autonomy rights and freedom the
mass demonstrations in the past have
included resistance against security
legislation official brainwashing
initiatives and the gutting of the
promised genuine universal suffrage
after the clearance of the Occupy
central sites democracy activists left a
promise inscribed on the concrete
sidewalks we will return they have kept
that promise
instead of Beijing's hoped for a
movement fatigue the protests supported
by unflagging solidarity and broad
diverse participation of Hong Kong
society are moving into the 15th week
pressing for now five non-negotiable
demands the out-of-control lawless
actions of the Hong Kong police have
provided mobilization fuel for Hong Kong
people to add oil as Chairman Mao said
wherever there is suppression
there will be resistance and at the
beginning of the Cultural Revolution he
also said anyone who crushes a student
moment movement will not have a good
ending the I want to talk about the rule
of law just briefly because there are
tensions that were baked into the one
country two systems framework making one
country one system or one-and-a-half
system perhaps an inevitable outcome
Taiwan's President Taeyang wins take
away from the current political crisis
hits the nail on the head
not only is one country two systems' not
a viable model for Taiwan but the Hong
Kong example proves that dictatorship
and democracy cannot coexist an
independent functioning rule of law is
essential yet the Chinese state
constitution and numerous high-level
policy pronouncements legitimizes the
subordination of law to the leadership
of the party the reintroduction of the
article 23 legislation that's in the
works in Hong Kong will inevitably
carried imprints of the parties concepts
of national security
second the demand for complete loyalty
to the party guts the independence of
key pillars of rule of law legal
profession and the media but Hong Kong
is not the mainland yet despite efforts
like the proposed Hong Kong national
anthem law and proposed loyalty
requirements loyalty pride and love
cannot be legislated so it's not
surprising that Hong Kong people miss
foreign business and the international
community have been alarmed the
outrageous and painful excessive
violence and abuse of law by the police
have already been extensively described
I will move to then talking about what's
at stake in terms of the universal
values China's aggressive activism at
the UN is undermining international
standards weakening the existing human
rights mechanisms and restricting the
participation of independent civil
society this cuts Hong Kong people as
well as human rights defenders on the
mainland and Tibetan and Weger
communities from the key international
platforms that's available
to press for accountability with this
instead of the West's hope for
convergence China is not only playing by
the rules
it is vocally and persistently asserting
a set of relativist criteria that it
alone can apply and pushing for Chinese
models of human rights democracy and
development that is no human rights no
development and no democracy this
rhetoric helps to intimidate silenced
and deflect from the accountability of
the state I want to point quickly to its
role in blocking independent voices
China sits on the ECOSOC Committee of
the UN and Gong goes who do not face any
objections such as the interruptions of
DS Denise hos recent intervention at the
Human Rights Council the intervention
last week by Patsy Howe the
representative the Hong Kong Federation
of women who is illustrative she not
only defended the SAR government's
handling of the protests but she accused
the Hong Kong protesters of child
exploitation and more Patsy Haute
co-chairman and director of Macau casino
operation and is also a Standing
Committee member of the Beijing
Municipal Committee of the Chinese
people's consultative conference because
I am out of time I want to really take
the time to jump ahead to the problem of
a in addition to the disinformation
campaign including the egregious use by
the China Daily on 911 of a photo
depicting the destruction of the World
Trade Towers to warn of terrorist
attacks by Hong Kong protesters Beijing
is advancing a narrative of violence to
frame the Hong Kong protests that is
echoed uncritically by the international
community within this framework the Hong
Kong police protected in full tactical
gear armed with rubber bullets guns tear
gas pepper spray and batons wielding the
coercive power of the state is presented
as one side of an escalating violence
clashes with civilian protesters hence
we hear both sides
to de-escalate but this deflects
attention away from police
accountability for its excessive use of
force and its complicity with non-state
violence
moreover the narrow violence framing of
the situation on the ground is erasing
or marginalizing intentionally the
proliferation of diverse kriesel
creative and peaceful protests by the
Hong Kong people including by students
and boycotts elderly citizens silver
hair volunteers protecting the children
actions Hong Kong people singing in the
malls in the metro stations and
neighborhood gatherings shouting the
10:00 p.m. shouts of slogans echoing
throughout all the neighborhoods in Hong
Kong and forming human chains creating
Lenin walls and last Friday was
mid-autumn festival and a small
family-owned bakery in Sai Wan made moon
cakes with protest slogans and in
typical humorous Hong Kong fashion Hong
Kongers are creating art this is what is
happening on the ground Hong Kong people
are practicing democracy and exercising
their freedoms for as long as possible
Hong Kongers are making the road by
walking it that is the real revolution
already underway thank you again and I
look forward to your questions well
thank you very much dr. Garrett thank
you for coming and we welcome your
testimony thank you good morning
chairman McGovern and Rubio
distinguished members of the Commission
it is an honor and privilege to talk
with you regarding the Chinese Communist
Party's erosion of one country two
systems' and Hong Kong under the pretext
of national security and its Nexus to
the extradition bill crisis I begin with
five key observations background the
current tronic Hong Kong conflict in the
one country two systems' crisis first
today's one country two systems' is not
the same as dong shoppings notion that
proffered peaceful coexistence between
the Communists and Hong Kong systems
instead it has been replaced by Xi
Jinping's new error one country two
systems model embracing political
struggle an enemy friend binary and
foregrounding Chinese national security
as the
lenz for governing the Special
Administrative Region and implementing
one country two systems rather than the
confidence-building mechanism and
sharing peaceful coexistence one country
two systems under Xi Jinping is now
intended to advance and safeguard
China's sovereignty security and
development interests to this new era
one country two systems' model is
informed by Xi Jinping's broader
national security concepts known as the
three major dangers and national
security with Chinese characteristics
the former situates communist China at
imminent risk of being invaded toppled
and separated in its development reform
instability sabotage thereby leading to
didi railing of China's rise socialist
modernization and the one country two
systems policy the latter dramatically
broadens the notion of Chinese national
security and radically expands the scope
of Chinese authorities prerogatives in
administering one country two systems
consequently it significantly erodes the
special administrative regions high
degree of autonomy diminishes Hong
Kongers freedoms and widens the threat
to u.s. citizens and national interests
in Hong Kong third under Xi Jinping's
new security paradigms and new one new
era one country two systems model
dissident Hong Kongers have been
systematically enemy fide and secured
eyes as mortal threats to the party
state and Bannon or removed from
positions of political power elections
have been partially nullified Hong
Kongers disenfranchised and terrorized
with real and rhetorical political
violence the promise of Hong Kong people
ruling Hong Kong has been effectively
replaced with the terror and achill role
of Patriots official declarations and
party state media propagating Hong
Konger enemy and Hong Kong threat
security discourses have become
ubiquitous and cultural revolution like
masse line and United Front denunciation
campaigns targeting Democrats localist
and westernized Hong Kongers have swept
the sea they repeatedly over the last
seven years since Xi Jinping came to
power four since at least 2012 Hong Kong
in one country two systems have been
perceived by Beijing as communist
China's weakest links in this resurgent
totalitarian national security state
for Chinese authorities both are at the
forefront of ideological confrontation
with the United States in the West a new
cold war in their terms by the end of
2014 and the umbrella movement the
struggle to rule Hong Kong was said to
have match the intensity surrounding the
1997 handover and that China had to now
rethink how to rule the Enclave an
influential advisor to Sinese senior
Chinese authorities said the Hong Kong
faces Society why quote/unquote long
term struggle to eradicate the party
states enemies in the city a de facto
Cultural Revolution that would involve
at a minimum rectifying and synthesizing
the judiciary legislature media
secondary schools and universities
Chinese and special administrative
regions furtive efforts to impose the
communists legal political and social
norms on Hong Kong by the extradition
law an unprecedent violent suppression
of protests have provoked the most
severe crisis of one country two systems
as Hong Kongers fight for during
dangered freedom's identity and way of
life this is not an anomaly it is a six
Chinese governance crisis involving one
country two systems since 2003 and the
fifth since Xi Jinping took control of
Hong Kong affairs each has an underlying
Chinese national security Nexus seeking
to broaden Beijing's powers its
so-called comprehensive jurisdiction in
Hong Kong
and to rollback Hongkongers high degree
of autonomy liberal freedoms and limited
democracy by forcibly transforming Hong
Kong and to a Chinese communist City
while maintaining a veneer of no changes
my next few observations will quickly
touch upon the extradition law Nexus to
national security
senior Chinese officials have described
the battle the extradition battle right
now as a quote unquote battle of life
and death and as a battle to defend Hong
Kong a decisive war defending one
countries or two systems or jeopardizing
it since 2000 since using pink came to
power national security is now a
mandatory obligation for people in the
Hong Kong SAR
this was never written in the original
basic law this has been done
post facto since 2012 early in the
extradition law saga senior Chinese
leaders have made extra extraordinary
endorsements of the extradition law
expressing their full support this
included two Politburo Standing
Committee members Han Zhang and Wong
young the head of the State Council's
Hong Kong and Macau Affairs Office Zhang
Xiao Ming and the chief to Hong Kong SAR
Laius on officer Long's our men there
are also indications that President Xi
Jinping as a member of the central
coordination group for Hong Kong and
Macau affairs has weighed in and then
influential United Front commentator and
state media has also observed that if it
were not for the full support of the
central government the legislation would
have been aborted chief executive Carrie
Lam recently lamented in the leaked
speech that since the issue had been
elevated to one of national security and
sovereignty it had stripped her of any
solutions or room for political maneuver
another source explained that because
the ELab involved in mainland Special
Administrative Region relationship with
the central government and the
implementation of the basic law it was
not a matter entirely within the
autonomy the Special Administrative
Region government this touches upon the
Hong Kong as five demands as well as US
national security u.s. policy towards
Hong Kong Beijing's in position of
Communists legal political and social
national security norms on Hong Kong's
constitute a violation of article 5 of
the basic law prohibiting the
introduction that socialist system in
the territory moreover the party's
application of its national security
with Chinese characteristics mandates
and loyalty expectations to the Special
Administrative Region and its civil
servants effectively dissolves any
difference between the communist and
Hong Kong systems thereby posing a
significant threat to US interests
related to the protection of sensitive
technologies and adherence to export
controls
I'll have two comments before I submit
the rest my testimony the Hong Kong
police force has been Miller to rise and
nationalized by the Chinese Communist
Party effectively becoming its little
gun in the Special Administrative Region
since the beginning of 2019 mainland
police have been tasked by President Xi
would quote unquote preventing
encountering color revolutions unquote
turn this Public Security Minister
subsequently ordered police to firmly
quote firmly fight to protect China's
political security unquote defend its
national security and the leadership of
the Communist Party earlier Hong Kong
police had received similar national
security tasking from Vice Premier Han
Zhang who in August 2018 charged them to
quote-unquote firmly in effectively
safeguard China's national security and
rule of law by accurately and
comprehensively implementing one country
two systems also according to a
vice-chairman the State Council's
Chinese Association of Hong Kong and
Macau studies the Hong Kong case for now
quote-unquote on the forefront when it
came to curbing Hong Kong independence
which meant their duty was not just a
maintain public order but to defend
national security to Chinese our chief
executive Carrie Lam in a leaked speech
also iterated that the Hong Kong police
were the only solution that they
currently possess in dealing with the
extradition process in no small way the
Hong Kong police have become the special
administrative regions people's armed
police well that's common Chinese
authorities have dedicated significant
academic legal political propaganda and
you nine different resources to
systematically manipulating and
recasting dong shoppings error content
understandings of the basic law in one
country two systems to accommodate Xi
Jinping's totalitarian national security
mandates logics and outlook a Chinese
Association of Hong Kong and Macau
studies or Hong Kong Macau Studies
Association a shadowy political warfare
like think-tank connected to the State
Council's Hong Kong and Macau Affairs
Office is one of these new subversive
vehicles can contantly a network of
party state constitutional and basic law
experts and scholars some attached to
the National People's Congress Standing
Committee
Kong Basic Law Committee have similarly
contributed significantly to the erosion
of one country two systems policy
mobilized political balance and informed
the central authorities understandings
of the actual situation in the region
all these united frontiers are key
players in the erosion of Hong Kong's
freedoms and democracy and the neighbors
of state tyranny thank you thank you
very much I'll save my questions to the
end I'm going to yield now to the
co-chair senator Rubio thank you and
I'll just ask one question because I
know members have places to go and I
want them to get in on this but um you
know the the sort of the the key issue
before us is autonomy if you go back in
2014 they took away universal suffrage
for the chief executive in 2016 and 17
they jailed or I'm sorry they
disqualified six Democratic lawmakers
from Ludd city council seats using a
very controversial interpretation of the
hong kong constitution and then in 2019
this effort at the extradition bill so
my question to all the panelists is how
would you describe the state of hong
kong autonomy today
[Music]
during the last congressional hearing I
scroll it aware how one country to
system eroded to be one country one and
a half system but the reason political
crisis by how Hong Kong and Beijing
government turns such a global city into
the Polish state with more violence and
even white terror
I would describe now is the collapse of
one country two system and also we are
safe we're facing the bath under the
current constitutional framework and I
think now is also the time and the
reason which we hope to seek for
bipartisan support support Hong Kong
civilization should not be the matter of
left or right issue better matter of
right or wrong so on a more cultural and
social context there is a immense fear
among the people to speak their minds
which is a result of how the businesses
and the government institutions they
have put pressure onto their employees
or the people to to keep their mouths
shut
basically and so this has a huge impact
on the economy because without this
freedom of speech it's it's very
difficult for the the economy and also
the society to thrive because in in the
sense we are already in somewhat of a
china city situation where people would
fear for their safety if they spoke out
about their political stance just for an
example there has been a an unofficial
hong kong anthem recently that has been
written by a anonymous songwriter and
they have opted to keep their Anan
anonymity because if they have shown the
faces then most probably they would have
been arrested or prosecuted because of
on claims of national threats national
security threats so that's basically the
sentiment on the grounds for Hong Kong
people last year the u.s. CC purpose a
report concerns that Hong Kong is
becoming more likely any like any other
Chinese city and that means that our
autonomy is already gone and actually
even the u.s. CC has issued a report who
came that the autonomy of Hong Kong is
already in danger in UK when I met some
politicians I would tell them that the
Chinese government already pitch the
sino-british joint declaration and
that's why I would say the autonomy of
Hong Kong is already dead and that's why
we urged the US government's and other
virial countries try to help with Hong
Kong with many like passing the human
rights an emergency adds and you can
pass the problematic see ads in other
countries urge your allies to pass them
to let other vivo countries to stand
with Hong Kong the the economy senator
rubio question is extremely important
because post 1989 that was the decision
that was made by the communist party
we're going to go forth back into market
and economic reforms but absolutely no
political reforms this has been echoed
by the chief executive when she
endlessly has been having these kind of
ridiculous press conferences where she
says nothing one thing she does say is
we need to restore the economy we need
to restore economic order and completely
ignoring the structural political issues
that is causing a lot of the fundamental
unrest so the other point I wanted to
add is that the Hong Kong economy was
not delivering the goods to most of the
Hong Kong people the tycoons and
probably the Triads were doing quite
well but not the majority of Hong Kong
people hence we have the housing problem
the education problem the problem of the
seat elderly with not adequate care and
so forth and health care so the economy
wasn't delivering and I think what needs
to happen yes there should be a renewal
of the economy but it's
gonna be an economy that works for all
the people if I could pick up quickly on
Sonny's reference to autonomy autonomy
what it means for the Communist Party is
we only need to look at the so called
autonomous regions of in Tibet and
cynjohn what autonomy means is no
cultural no language no history no right
to believe or practice your faith under
the sinuses ation of religion which is
an oxymoron and their understanding of
autonomy even extends to pass this print
life as you know the party is trying to
now control reincarnation so they also
try to impose a notion of chineseness
what kind of chineseness well Xi
Jinping's notion of chineseness under
the Chinese dream and what is Chinese
but Hong colors are quite complex as a
history and language and culture and I
think Hong Kongers are going and are
negotiating what it means to be a Hong
Kong whether it includes being a Chinese
doesn't mean that and I think that's
what it means to be free the right to
decide and determine in this complex way
what does it mean to be who we are and
that is absolutely antithetical to the
DNA of the Communist Party and its
notion of autonomy because it doesn't
exist thank you
the rule of patriots in Hong Kong
basically means that there is no
substantive high degree of autonomy
basically undershooting ping a
democratic centralism is practice they
may solicit input from the Hong Kong
government but once Beijing makes a
decision
the SAR government has to implement it
building on the doctor homes comments
here national identity is now a national
security issue for the Communist Party
in Hong Kong and they believe that one
of the major problems this goes back to
2007 when who Gentile told the Hong Kong
government a 10th anniversary that the
SAR government had to create a new
generation of Hong Kongers who loved one
country two systems' who love China that
the recovery of Hong Kong
would not be complete until Hongkongers
identified with China with communist
China this also touches on Xi Jinping's
Chinese communist identity politics
which is attempting to rehabilitate the
spoiled image of the Communist Party in
the sport image of being a communist
this is why we start seeing laws
protecting the national anthem martyrs
and so forth like this and so in Hong
Kong which has always been historically
anti-communist to a large degree there
is this effort related to the
extradition campaign to eradicate
so-called anti-communist sentiment and
anti-communist forces with regards to
autonomy because the belt and Road
initiative and the greater Bay Area
initiatives are key to China's
development program right now and
because the central government believes
that the major impediment to hong kong
signing on and strongly supporting these
programs has been the two systems
husband it's democracy husband it's
freedoms it is now looking to restrict
those in order to force the SAR
government to support these programs so
once again in closing i would say there
is no substantive autonomy thank you
thank you mrs. Swasey well thank you mr.
chairman and chairman rubio for holding
this hearing we appreciate you bringing
us together thank you Chairman's
representative Smith ranking member
Smith for the work that you've done this
issue for so many years thank you to the
witnesses we are so grateful to all of
you for the information you've given us
here today and for shining a light on
this I know we we sit here in this in
this chamber it's very calm it's very
safe it's very sterile and you're
bringing to life what's going on in real
people's lives right now when you talk
about a 12 year old being arrested we
hear the idea that someone gets pepper
spray sprayed into their wound when we
see here about people's heads being
smashed into the concrete and getting
concussions and we hear about the rubber
bullets and the tear gas and everything
else and people living in fear on a
regular basis for standing up for
speaking their minds here
United States of America we've believed
for since Nixon went to China that the
more that China was exposed to our way
of life in the United States and to the
West that they would become more like us
we always thought they'd become you know
they if they saw capitalism they saw
democracy sooner or later they'd become
more and more like us and we now know
that that's not at all the case
whether the hearings we've held about
the we Gers oh the hearings about Tibet
or now about Hong Kong we know that
they're they're probably what you know
we talk about Hong Kong as being as
being one country two systems'
it's really one world with two models
and they're meeting each other in Hong
Kong right now and the question is which
model is gonna win is gonna be the model
that we promote here in the United
States with the rule of law and with
freedom of expression and with democracy
or is it going to be authoritarianism
and and the the powerful forces of the
government doing whatever they want
whatever they way they want their
meeting right there and you're right in
the middle of that challenge right now
so we're so grateful to all of you so
I'm concerned about the timing of things
right now
you know we're pushing to get this bill
passed here in the Congress but right
now we've got I think you talked about
it Joshua the national day in China is
coming up on October 1st and I'm
concerned about what mainland China's
actions are gonna be in relation to that
and whether there'll be more violence
will result as they try to flex their
authority and I'd like to hear each of
you talk about that and the second thing
I'm concerned about are the local
elections coming up in November and I
want to hear about from you about the
whether you believe that there's an
opportunity here for the people of Hong
Kong to express themselves or is there
being or is a mainland trying to subvert
that by not permitting certain
candidates to run and and not giving
them permission to run which is you know
a foreign idea to hear us here in the
United States of America but so
important to all of you and the third
timing is is let's say a magic wand it
was all of a sudden waved and and and in
mainland China said you know we're going
to support the idea of there being
elections in the future in in high
Kong for the for the leader instead of
Carrie Lim being appointed in an
election by the people that couldn't
happen right away it would take some
time I'd like to hear what you think
about the timing so let's try and keep
it brief I know I talked a lot myself
and used up a lot of time but please
just October 1st election day and how
impactful that can be and what the
timing would be if they were to agree as
one of the five demands that there would
be universal suffrage so Josh will you
go first please apart from apart from
troops were already moved to the border
few weeks ago that's the tactics for
Beijing of Frosty's to generate the
chilling effect we strongly aware on how
Carol am the lead of Hong Kong openly
declared that she is considering to
impose emergency ordinance in Hong Kong
to stop the protests emergency ordinance
is the colonial era law similar as
martial law it authorized the power for
chief executive of Hong Kong to shut
down the internet cut the public
transport and even cut the air traffic
we all know that political crisis must
solve by political system reform that's
the reason we urged Beijing not to
handpick the leader please let us enjoy
the right of free election but they just
conduct and consider to use this kind of
martial law before or after the Chinese
National Day I think that's the reason
not only people with Defense on human
rights must scare about even businessmen
that focus on an enjoying economic
freedom and open this environment they
should aware on how Hong Kong is not
only on the brain of Rochette it's also
under the threat of those martial law
and white terror so I really hope to
have bipartisan support to pass the Hong
Kong human rights and democracy act
after explaining what's happening before
after Chinese national day the upcoming
district council elections scheduled on
24th of November with the track record
of how Beijing unseat democratically
elected lawmakers including Nathan law
and Agnes Charlotte the one who hope to
run for office on early last year we
strongly expect and aware that Beijing
will still keep its hardline policy to
Hong Kong and to block or by youngster
to run for office as the one who engaged
in street activism
hope the wars of young generation could
be hurt inside the institution and at
the same time I'm also will make sure
that announcement beef in the late
September or early October for myself
will run for office on the District
Council or not if Beijing government
banned me to run for office Damon needs
to pay the price on this on Hong Kong
keep on Hong Kong protests and also in
the international communities so in Hong
Kong there are many pent democratics and
many pro-beijing folks is there a chance
that that could change that that dynamic
could change because of the protests
that are going on in this reckon so we
have 450 two seats and more than 75% of
the seat are all mostly dominated by
pro-beijing camp and on 24 of november
we hope pro-democratic hem can get a
good turnout to show the power of people
so I just want to you know emphasize the
timing coming up October 1st in November
24th or big days they could have a big
impact on what Beijing is doing and what
is happening from the people and it
could be a flashpoint we have to be very
conscious of that Denise do you want to
go ahead yes personally I don't feel
that October 1st would be something she
stopped the people from going onto the
streets as the sentiment is still very
very determined and very strong among
all walks of life and so that this fight
has been able to sustain itself because
of this sort of creativity and the
flexibility of the people and so I
believe that without a sincere answer or
solution from the government the people
won't be backing down and so on the on
the side of how the communist government
they would be suppressing us on the even
escalating level I don't think no
personally I feel that there are
probably already Chinese police among
the Hong Kong police force there have
been several occasions where the police
commanders have been hurt talking the
Mandarin to their offices so I know on
this note I believe that Hong Kong
people are
facing this sort of infiltration of the
Chinese police into the Hong Kong police
force so are you concerned about it
escalating around national day um well I
mean it's already on a daily basis of
this sort of escalation where the police
are patrolling the streets people are
rested no just for for being young
really so I I think we are already at
that stage and so know that that is why
we call for the US Congress and also
international communities to monitor
this regime that is the the Xi Jinping
regime because we in Hong Kong we are
protecting these values that we all
believe in and if we fail then you know
what what knows what would happen to the
world and to the next stage thank you
honey yes thank you for your question
personally I think on on the national
day actually
there will be more escalation on the
movements and because I know that the
Chinese Authority must want the Hong
Kong people try to respect the National
Day but on the other hand Hong Kong
protester they know that they also know
that is important to have some symbolic
movement on the National Day and that's
why there will be some escalation of the
movement but I doubt if the Chinese
government they dare to use the
emergency law or send up send out to the
PLA
to come to Hong Kong because currently
China relies on Hong Kong very much many
foreign investment from China is still
coming from Hong Kong and that's why
once if they deport the PLA or try to
use emergency law to crack down on Hong
Kong protests I think this is not very
promising for Hong Kong people for the
for the Beijing government and [ __ ]
example governments will not do
something like that I've you Sharon if
you could talk about the elections a
little bit also
I think a couple things I wanted is
really important that hasn't been raised
in addition to the question of
infiltration and use of decoys last
August
2018 the People's Daily announced the
establishment of the greater Bay Area
police cooperation mechanism among
Guangdong Hong Kong and Macau related to
and part of this mechanism the Guangdong
public security department conducted
training of key Hong Kong police
personnel in Guangdong this has been
followed up on and one of the questions
I think is important to press either
through the UN systems is to raise the
question of really what kind of training
I am pretty sure that the training did
not include international standards on
appropriate use of force and the special
procedures of the UN special experts
just last week issued a joint statement
about concern and also raising these
questions of the need to make the police
the Hong Kong police there are very
sophisticated detailed standards on the
use of force and that you supposed to
de-escalate not escalate you're supposed
to reduce harm not create harm and that
there are a whole range of police crowd
control mechanisms and they're supposed
to choose according to proportionality
so I wanted to just emphasize that on
the timing of national day I think we
can't lose sight of the fact that Xi
Jinping is not as powerful as we may
think or as he would like us to think
and that it is true that with the
consolidation of power etc etc and his
no term limit now both of the key
positions the fact is what you're
getting to see the tea leaves if you
look a little more closely is that the
party leaders inside are not happy with
the way that Xi Jinping has quote
handled the Hong Kong situation and how
do we know this we know this because
Carrie Lam the chief executive on a
Monday I believe said no no no no
withdrawal no no
no etcetera cetera I withdrew it no
formal two days later that kind of
disingenuous explanation I have heard
the Hong Kong people but goodness sakes
it spent three months if you can't hear
two million three million people why in
two days that she suddenly say I will
now formally so Xi Jinping is actually
in a lose-lose situation it's a no-win
situation he's stuck between the
hardliners who I am pretty much
concerned about are pushing for military
force like because he has already shown
he's failed Tung shell pink took two
months shut down the whole eighty nine
student and the democracy and free trade
union movement we are now in the third
month so under the party's dead
timeframe on how you can handle these
mass disputes he has failed so he's in a
pretty dicey situation October 1st this
is not any anniversary this is the 70th
anniversary so they have invested a
year's worth of enormous investment in
film festival special documentaries made
they have said that no Chinese
documentaries in this you know Chinese
TV recently they have to show the
history and etc there's an enormous
amount of investment to keep the
legitimacy and have a wonderful birthday
celebration for the for the country so
he stuck it can't look bad on the other
hand he's stuck between the hardliners
and the others who are saying there's
got to be a way to handle this not the
way you're doing it because now we look
terrible now we look like the thugs we
are and so I think that that is what we
should be monitoring are the messages
and just last week a very strange
editorial appeared in tea oh sure which
as you know is one of the major party
organs and in to assure the editorial
pointed out something very strange it
said whether a country's political this
is art our our translation sorry whether
a country's political system is
democratic and effective one needs to
mainly look at whether the country's
leadership ranks can rotate or alternate
B&T in a
hortence with the law in an orderly
fashion what does this mean we don't
know because just the fact that the
Constitution eliminated the term limits
for the top office doesn't mean he'll
stay so I think there are some other
wild cards that are on the table that we
need to keep an eye on in terms of how
the US government can think about the
options and policy options of course we
support the legislative initiatives this
is very important but I think there's
something much bigger underway in terms
of the politics in Beijing that will
absolutely have an impact on the
decisions that will be made
pre-op Toba first and after thank you
I've Dan I've taken up too much time I'm
going to move on to what we hold in our
young I just have a statement to make
and I regret I'm gonna have to leave
after this but I wanted to say thank you
mister Wong thank you ms Howe for your
courage for your resolve for your
leadership in the face of a great trial
and tribulation thank you for the
example you're setting for the world and
for all that you're doing for
freedom-loving peoples I want to send a
message to Beijing's Communists and my
message is you cannot have it both ways
you cannot seek to trade with the
wealthy nations of the world and rip off
our intellectual property you cannot
seek to be a trusted international
development partner and engage in
predatory economic practices through
your belt and road initiative and you
cannot reap all the economic benefits
that you enjoy under American law of
Hong Kong special status while
undermining your rights as Hong Kongers
while eradicating your political
identity we cannot allow this to happen
so I look forward to working with you I
will be signing on to the legislation
offered by the co-chairman of this
committee as you have encouraged us to
do so and I'll be seeking other
opportunities perhaps in the immigration
area to provide further relief to Hong
Kongers who do not want to be a part of
this predatory regime that calls itself
communist but in fact is is is really
fascist in many respects and and we must
continue to press it to change its
behavior thank you so much for your
presence here mr. Smith Thank You mr.
chairman
there is no disputing the fact that
under Xi Jinping human rights abuses
have seriously worsened you name the
area from torture religious freedom this
home you talked about the sanitization
of religions where every single religion
or faith including the Falun Gong
Christians Tibetan Buddhists the weekers
all has to comport to to the communist
model or else face severe torture
incarceration and even death it is it is
incredible what he is doing in his
regime and of course all of that will be
imposed on Hong Kong unless there is a
reversal of this trend on human
trafficking the Trump administration is
designated China as a Tier three country
because of sex and labor trafficking it
has gotten seriously worse over the last
several years so every place you look
it is worse she's praying is is bringing
dishonor to himself and to his
government with his abuse of people and
I think we need to say that loud and
clear you know the great father of
democracy waging showing once said and I
had him at a hearing and I actually met
him in Beijing when he was let out
briefly they get Olympics 2000 which the
Chinese government didn't get so they
really manned beat him almost senseless
well he said you know you Westerners
don't get it you do coddle dictatorship
you do allow and enable by your weakness
you've got to look a dictatorship in the
eye and say we're not kidding condition
that with me of human rights either
occurs or we're not going to be trading
with you and allowing you to use
that economic power that you get to
further incarcerate and further repress
you know the lessons of the Soviet Union
were not learned when it came to China I
got elected 1981 my first trip was to
Moscow Leningrad on behalf of Soviet
Jews and frankly the Reagan
administration stood up strongly to the
powers in Moscow and said human rights
matter and it did matter and we
thankfully we saw a change of course
under Putin it's still bad but not as
bad as it was during those years I
raised all of that because when it came
to China we have not learned the lessons
of conditionality with regards to human
rights and I say that with sadness
with great sadness you know when we did
the comprehensive anti-apartheid Act in
1986 not only did I vote for it but we
had a world coalition saying this
egregious behavior will not be tolerated
therefore we're gonna hold you to
account and no longer provide munitions
which mr. McGovern's bill which I have
co-sponsored would seek to do with the
police that was section 3 1 7 I believe
of that bill and mr. Garre you might
want to speak to that but we've got to
be serious about all of this and I just
bring this up because it deeply concerns
me that we just keep not learning the
lessons Nancy Pelosi Frank wolf David
bonheur and I all opposed
MFN for China after Tiananmen Square
George Herbert Walker Bush thought he
could manage the whole thing he was our
ambassador to China and as it turned out
we managed it extraordinarily poorly
Bill Clinton came in and he said let's
link human rights with MFN trade one
year later he delinked it and the lesson
learned by the dictatorship in Beijing
was profits Trump human rights we now
and I have tried for five years to get
my bill passed our bill it's a
collective bill
House and Senate bipartisan and the same
people who said just trade more and
somehow [ __ ] matriculate from
dictatorship to democracy have been
proven wrong again and if it wasn't for
the great people of Hong Kong
standing up so powerfully at great loss
of their of their Liberty going to
prison being arrested being harassed and
even killed and tortured that this
Congress needs to wake up and say
finally at long last we're gonna put
conditionality on this so if you want to
speak to that
I would appreciate it there have been a
thousand arrests since the activities
occurred what is the status of the
prosecution's in Joshua we know you know
your case but there are many other cases
that are in obscurity right now what is
happening to those individuals and just
generally on the police are the police
largely newer recruits who were more
ideologically aligned with Beijing or
they the old hands who have just now
become even more repressive than they
had been in the past if you could speak
to those things I would appreciate it
[Music]
with more than 1500 Hongkong were
arrested in the past three months more
than 200 of them were prosecuted already
I'm among one of them and we're also
aware on some of those activists were
already detained at inside prison before
any trial start and that's the
sugar-coated rule of law and a Hong
kong-style
legal system under the pressure of
Beijing I've been arrested and
prosecuted with the charges of
unauthorized assembly even after
experience to be jailed for around 100
handi base but the price I pay is just a
small piece of cake because lost of our
teammates I from my understanding more
than hundred of them face the rio
charges might be locked up in prison for
more than ten years five years ago
during an umbrella movement we were just
arrested by an unlawful assembly little
face maybe months a one to two years in
jail but now the answer at the age of 15
they should enjoy the summer holiday
they should spend the time more time in
the summer vacation with the friends and
family but now they are the one being
prosecuted and need to face a trial and
maybe from 15 or 16 at the age the
golden year
for themselves maybe already need to be
a lot of imprison and also we have
activists at what learn who fight for
Hong Kong's freedom already being a lot
women presenting this face six years in
prison apart from the massive arrest and
prosecution it seems to be the tactics
for Beijing to silence our voice but
with how a movement still keep our
momentum just like two weeks ago more
than 200,000 Hong Kong's
March to us u.s. consulates in Hong Kong
urge to pass the bill and to show the
global solidarity we also aware that the
Cabinet of chief executive which means
member from the Executive Council last
week openly declare that Hong Kong's
chief executive enjoyed the right to
appoint at any secret police secret
police is not the terms created by
activists or great by journalists is the
terms written in the current ordinance
and regulation it could authorize the
power for Hong Kong chief executive to
appoint anyone no matter the live in
Hong Kong they live in England or live
in they or they would have roofing and a
kind of background they can be appointed
to be the Hong Kong police force and
continue to use life threatening force
to crack down on our protest and that's
the white terror and why all of us will
describe Hong Kong is a Paulo state I
would like to add to the fact that among
those who have been arrested and charged
for riot a lot of them have been on the
sites but they have not been in the
front lines they were just near the
front lines and some of them have been
First Aiders who have been helping other
people getting up and getting away from
the sites social workers and of course
the legislators who have been arrested
they were not charged for riot but you
know that that is something that is
shocking to the Hong Kong people to have
these legislators arrested and so on top
of that I would like to add that the
situation that is in Hong Kong it is
spreading into the international world
where
this communist tactic of no silencing
people with fear and also with money
it's it's everywhere
really it's not only in Hong Kong as I
said just now there have been incidents
in Australia where government of
institutions they have kept away from me
and another Chinese artists for for fear
of being associated with us and also in
Canada where Hong Kong activists have
been banned from a gay pride know who
because of security concerns so they say
and so the the fact that is the
communist government they they use this
sort of the money where the brands and
businesses they would be adding this
sort of suppression on to their
employees and other people and then
everyone would be just silencing
themselves so this also would cause is
causing a lot of fear among Hong Kong us
and that is why this movement has been
largely anonymous because we know that
for a fact if we show our faces then we
would be arrested and prosecuted for
riot or unlawful assembly
I would like to supplement what the
penis has just mention about still the
problematic law actually the Human
Rights Council of the United Nation has
decried the public order ordinance which
is a colonial law in Hong Kong the
departments of justice and police force
in Hong Kong they can use this pub all
the ordinance to prosecute those
protester we have a very easy way that
means that once if the DOJ the
Department of Justice or the police
force they try to use the public all the
ordinance to persecute the protester and
then actually it's very difficult for
them to be to be not sued as guilty and
that's why this law should be abolished
by the government and we urge that
actually the international society
should also be aware about this law
apart from that I had experience I had a
personal experience that a kid of III
had a real kid and then he was arrested
in one of the political dis built around
the confrontation around during the
movement and that kid was Randy when
that kid was arrested and he immediately
asked the police officer official
officer to as him can he call his lawyer
and the police officer they told him
that of course you can't because I want
to torture you because I want to make
you suffer and these police officers
they said something like that to a kid
who is just under 18 and this is a real
situation in Hong Kong that why that's
why many people are very frustrated and
angry about the police without any
problem the the prosecution's is related
to not only the imposition of the public
order
but ordinance it has to be an unlawful
assembly so the way in which the notice
of no objection process contributes to
that that's the tool and the tool is
Hong Kongers and face this ridiculous
situation where they have to have the
police deny the application for a notice
of no objection for a file for a group
for a peaceful assembly that is to
protest police violence so you have the
police denying the notice of no assembly
therefore making it an unlawful assembly
you know for an assembly that is to
protest police violence so that's really
important that through this kind of
misuse of that process they are really
violating international standards for
peaceful assembly by imposing this kind
of unduly restrictive Administrative
Procedure the police under this
procedure then can act rampantly as both
enforcement prosecutor
because they're naming this saying this
is a riot but a riot is a legal process
it's for the court to look at the
evidence it's for the court to see if
this person engaged in illegal behavior
and violent etc so right now the police
are acting as enforcement prosecution
and executioner of orders and that is
part of the problem with looking at when
we talk about political and on top of
that we have politicized decision-making
by the prosecution this was also noted
by independent UN experts civil maybe
two years ago saying that they were
concerned about a potential pattern of
politicized decisions that were being
made in who to prosecute and who to
pursue know who to to pursue there is an
issue regarding whether or not Hong
Kongers can get a fair trial and Hong
Kong in the future and a large reason
for this is the heavy amount of
propaganda coming from the central
People's Government whether it isn't
chinese state media organizations or it
is in so-called mainstream organizations
who quote them and cite them
ubiquitously so when the regime Chinese
regime characterized demonstrators as
separatists extremists terrorists this
is already setting an expectation for
the Hong Kong judiciary to act not just
as well as law enforcement not only in
the charges that they decide to delay
against a protester but also the
sentences that they're trying to get
after people the pro Beijing United
Front movement in Hong Kong has been
very aggressive and attacking judges
that it feel that have been too lenient
with protesters and this goes back in
number of years they derogatorily refer
to him CLL judges referring to the
yellow ribbons from the umbrella of
revolution there's been threats made by
pro-beijing people towards the judiciary
in general
you
mentioned by the National People's
Congress there is an expectation that
Hong Kong judges have to uphold the
national security of the Communist Party
so if you render a decision that is
inconsistent with that national security
expectation you may be vulnerable to
disqualification now this has not
happened but this is a logic that is
being used to disqualify candidates of
the District Council the Legislative
Council elections and so forth regarding
the police touching Insurance comments
earlier the Hong Kong police also went
to shin heung as observers to learn on
how they handled quote-unquote mass
incidents and there's very little
visibility on that we know that the PLA
in Hong Kong there are some interaction
with them the hong kong pla garrison
commander observed some of their passing
out their parades and so forth like that
but one of the most dangerous and I
think terrifying things for most Hong
Kongers is that the Hong Kong police now
act without wearing uniforms without any
type of identification you can be
grabbed off the street you can make grab
from your home nobody's showing you any
type of formal identification you don't
know if there are a police officer you
don't know if there are a triad a
patriotic vigilante or if somebody from
the mainland kidnapping you so this is a
major issue now for the Communist Party
they viewed law enforcement as their
concept of rule of law or rule by law
and so the support basically the Hong
Kong police have been given carte
blanche to do whatever they want and
this carry Liam said before the Hong
Kong police are seen as the last line in
this so they're the policing issue is a
major problem in Hong Kong
senator King mr. chairman representing
Adams was here long before I arrived so
I'll defer to him thank you Thank You
senator today marks a significant day in
United States history it was 232 years
ago on this very day that our
forefathers signed the United States
Constitution so it's I think with some
significance that we welcome you here
today to the United States Congress the
House and the Senate to share your
testimonies and and as you share in this
struggle this global struggle of
humanity for freedom and independence so
that that Constitution signed 232 years
ago today created a federal system one
with a Senate and a house that
oftentimes by design are in there's some
tension between these two bodies it
created three branches of government and
executive branch legislative branch in a
judicial branch it's an outgrowth of
that system as our two political party
so that oftentimes also struggle for for
ideas to move forward it created a
system of a federal system with now 50
states that also there's a healthy
tension sometimes unhealthy but there's
a tension between though that system as
we struggle to move forward ideas and
end a rule of law one thing that I think
it's important to note though is that we
all stand together this is a legislative
and executive branch that we stand
together Republicans and Democrats in
support of the struggle for human rights
for the rule of law and for freedom for
Hong Kong and I would echo the the
sentiments that have been expressed
earlier that you cannot we cannot have
it both ways we cannot have a rule of
law and human rights and the struggle
for freedom with the actions that we see
that are undermining the very the very
nature of that system in Hong Kong today
and so it's incredibly troubling to me
to see what we have seen play out over
the last six months
and forecasting into the future some of
the efforts to undermine the sanctuaries
of democracy and human rights that we
see right now so some of those
sanctuaries and foundations of freedom
as we've seen in the United States and
we also see in Hong Kong the the freedom
of democracy and government through
elections the freedom of academia and
for ideas to thrive in an academic
system the freed economic freedom for
individuals and an economic competition
and rule of law where every individual
is treated fairly and equally under the
law and human rights are protected so my
concern what I'd love for you to comment
on is where we go from here and with
some very troubling signs on the horizon
so I'd like you to comment on mr. Wong
and let me commend all of you who are
examples and and the founders of freedom
whose names I hope will be remembered
two hundred thirty two years from now in
the struggle for freedom in Hong Kong
but Mr Wong MS ho mr. Chung and miss
Hong for your efforts and struggles for
Hong Kong the I'd love for you to
comment on first of all mr. Wong I'm the
struggles in in elections for
individuals to step forward I've I'm
over the last several years the
government has as you referenced has
repeatedly rejected the nomination of
candidates running for political office
who have supported or been affiliated
with self-determination what challenges
does that impose today and going forward
for individuals who are willing to to
put their themselves and their names
forward taking that same look at the
foundations of freedom of thought to
academia what support our academic
academic institutions give to students
as they raise their voices in support of
intellectual freedom and human rights
and also to the economy and free economy
as businesses miss Howe I believe as you
spoke about some of the concerns with
Cathay Pacific and
and efforts that undermine individuality
and freedom of thought of in the
marketplace of ideas in the workplace
what is what is happening in these
respective spheres and foundations of
democracy and how can we best support
freedom of thought so just let me
explain what's on the mind of the young
generation in the past few years after
the end of umbrella movement loss of
youngster domain her they are whole
different kind of political tea live
they still have the awareness and
consensus they hope their words can be
heard inside its institution
apart from talk to the street joining
protest is also silicon's for us for
push forward political system and
election reform unfortunately with those
political censorship even I'm
considering to run for office and I will
make the formal announcement on late of
September or early October
I still aware that how Beijing hope to
bar the whole generation of youngster to
enter the institution but it's lucky
that with the determination and courage
of Hong Kong as they just turned the
whole generation of youngster to be
dissident and not only the generation of
baby boomers even the generation of Gen
X and Minami O's or they join the fight
with solidarity and unity so I would
just make it clear Hong Kong is not only
suffering from the political crisis we
are also suffering from the humanitarian
crisis especially how Hong Kong police
force just hardly hardline suppressed on
us no matter the sexual harassment
experienced by young lady arrested or
how injured protester would be pulled
down from the ambulance by riot police
directly or how arrested person is is
really difficult for them and when we
feel it the contact lawyer or even seek
for any kind of medical treatment I
think this kind of hotline suppression
we just heard hole of my generation and
a generation younger than me no matter
on the street or get inside the
institution we will keep on together
with this up
battle and we hope the US Congress can
stand with Hong Kong
I'll go okay so yes on the on the
cultural side and also on the the
freedom of thought side of things it has
been 90 percent of it probably has been
eroded where at least the the whole show
business has been in is in the control
of the communist government me along
with just a very small handful of actors
and singers have spoken up for these
movements but the rest of the
celebrities they have kept the silence
and they have been forced into
participating in these support campaigns
on social media of I support the Hong
Kong police or I am a protector of the
national flag campaigns where they have
to voice out the support see the the
Chinese government or else they would be
prosecuted you know censored like people
like us so businesses of course they
have been pressured also into
obstructing these freedoms of Hong Kong
as namely MTR of subway system they have
closed down stations in times of protest
therefore making it very easy for the
police to arrest people and also very
difficult for the people to leave the
sites and that was a result of I believe
it was an article that was in the
People's Daily the state newspaper where
they have named the MTR Oh copper
corporation saying that they have been
helping the people so I do think that in
a free society these businesses and
corporations they do have a obligation a
social responsibility to keep up this
kind of integrity to at least safeguard
our freedoms which they have failed to
do so and like right now we we do have
do not have much solutions to these
problems because aside of
people protesting these businesses they
are exercising their suppression onto
their people so we hope that this Hong
Kong Human Rights and the mask and the
democracy act with there's these
sanctions on on the government officials
and hopefully you know if this could
extend to these corporations who have
been violating the basic law the freedom
of speech and of the people hopefully
that this would be monitoring the the
businesses and also of course the
government institutions in hong kong
from the academic perspective i believe
we still have we need to have a correct
understanding on china first figures in
1989 when professor Fukuyama famously
declared that this is the end of the
history because he believed democracy is
the ultimate form of human governments
and the the ideology communism or other
of a terrorism who have no place in a
coming world but apparently two decades
after he he gave his speech he's wrong
and we cannot still using the mindset of
the old times that we can be that we
should continue the engagement policy
towards China we should abandon the
engagement policy and try to use a more
assertive way try to understand China
because in the campus we know that
Chinese government they try to establish
a lot of Confucius Institute around the
world and by that convinces into Tuesday
as they are creating propaganda try to
influence the views in other countries
including your peers and this is not
reasonable candidate performance last
year they started to shut down some of
the Confucius Institute and I believe
actually these are Google fright because
when we uphold the academic freedom and
freedom of speech in the campus the
Chinese government apparently they do
not agree on that and where many Hong
Kong people
over the past few months they support
their movements in Hong Kong and they
have organized a lot of rallies across
the globe in Australia in UK in u.s.
they have received a lot of retinic
letters and they are being followed
their home addresses are being posted on
those social medias and that's why we
need the all the viewer countries
including us to support Hong Kong people
in the campus and to uphold the attend
they were to support the academic
freedom in a long run thank you
I think the the question that every that
all of this also is related to is China
is clear exercise of soft heart and
shock power and so I want to say a
couple things on the academic front in
the u.s. we have over 300,000 Chinese
students from the mainland and also
students elsewhere I think Joshua saw
recently close up and personal when he
spoke at Columbia what the actions of
the students are I'm not raising it to
think that there's an easy answer but I
do think that we must be thinking about
how do we and I use it for lack of a
better word engage the fact that we're
welcoming students into u.s.
institutions I taught I teach a human
rights course at NYU as well as an and I
had some main lenders who did not want
to take my course because they're afraid
to take the course because if they take
the course other people were reporting
on who took the course
why Sharon you know human rights in
China director and then even recently if
I had students in the class as observers
or whatever from the mainland something
that the censorship is on mainland
students as well so we do have them
protesting but we also have to recognize
they are all under surveillance with
families back home I really want to echo
Denise's call to bring in the role of
the companies and in particular as the
protect Hong Kong act moves forward in
discussions and I know that it's going
through a legislative process I think it
would be really good to think about and
address the question of the US companies
because not only will the denial of
export licenses really address the issue
it will address the issue of no longer
being complicit but will it address the
issue of the actual category of lethal
and non-lethal materials and I wanted to
point out that China hosts the China
International Exhibition on police
equipment every two years the next one
they all held in Beijing will be held on
May 12th to the 15th that's a really
important date and they sell and they
have thousands of exhibitors from all
over the world and companies and in the
past we have been monitoring many US
companies have gone to exhibit and sell
and then afterwards report very proudly
on the the are we singing yeah not yet
okay yeah not singing yet but they've
also reported on the hundreds the
millions of dollars of contracts that
they were able to secure in Beijing so I
think one thought might be to aside from
or in addition to export licenses
what about technology transfers what
about collaboration what about them
training the Chinese partner companies
what about what are the other things
that need to be in place so that because
China has been named an economic
competitor for the US it's not an even
playing field they're an economic
competitor where the SOE so dominating
the economy you are not investing in all
your company US companies but China is
investing in all the key industries and
that is technology and AI the military
sector financial services and then the
ICT sector which is completely
state-owned enterprise in terms of the
key ICT so I want to ask one final
thought for what can be done going
forward next year on the Human Rights
Council at the end of this year China
rotates off and according to the rules
can't come back on in 2020 I think that
is the year in which the US government I
know you have left the council for
various analysis of its effectiveness
but that does not take away the fact
that the u.s. is still viewed as a
leading player among all the member
states on the council you can exercise
your role as an observer
you can also exercise your very
influential role in working with other
democratic governments to issue joint
statements joint initiatives in joint so
I think 2020 is particularly important
and in particular that is a year to push
because you are also on the NGO
committee of ECOSOC that is the year to
support and push for the reforms that
are needed to allow independent civil
society groups to be able to participate
as you know my organization has had
applied for ECOSOC status and over the
last 30 years and both times you can't
make it out of the NGO committee because
China just looks at us and goes and
that's it it's end of story
so I think it's very important that the
u.s. can raise the issues not only as an
observer and Human Rights Council but in
the General Assembly and and I know
you're quite active on the third and
fifth committees that's where I think
it's really important to exercise
leadership 2020 is the year you can push
this China will be there with its client
states and threatening everybody else to
support them while they're not there but
the point is they won't have a vote so I
think it's a good year to get some
traction
I'll just make a couple quick comments
one is US has law enforcement
cooperation with the Hong Kong police
and this may need to be considered or
look at more strongly in the future
second basically as far as companies go
in Hong Kong there's at one country two
systems' apartheid like system where a
patriot patriotic companies are
privileged over other companies if you
happen to be a pro-democracy supporter
you're at the bottom if not an enemy
regarding Hong Kong universities if I
remember correctly there's seven public
ones they're all funded by the SAR
government so this put some pressure on
the type of academic agendas research
interests and so forth like this and
there are real problems if you're
considered a sensitive personality such
as benny tai or if you're researching
sensitive issues that may or may not be
quote clearly evident there's also a lot
of things that happens on hong kong we
got related to academic and other
freedoms that are above the water and
below the water line one of them is one
of the things that the Hong Kong police
are doing right now are ID checks writ
large so even if you're not arrested
your name is being recorded and
associated as being at a protest site
now this may come down later on and some
hiring decision some vetting process by
state-owned enterprises or other
patriotic Hong Kong companies former
chief executive CY long discuss such a
possibility back I think I was around
2014 or 2012 and my last comment would
be that Chinese state-owned enterprises
incorporated in Hong Kong should not be
treated as Hong Kong companies thank you
thank you I know we have two senators
here there's a vote on and so I may
yield to Senator King but I would just
keep our answers short so they both can
get their questions and I think that
would be helpful senator King thank you
miss home I'm struggling with the fact
that we've got an island of democracy in
a sea of repression you've got a country
which is now seems to be perfecting the
controls
state millions of cameras facial
recognition repression of the weekers
religion everything and yet you've got
Hong Kong the two you've got two
societies moving in the opposite
direction very briefly what's the
solution or is there one where does this
end as a practical matter I mean it's a
practical matter there's seven million I
understand Hong Kongers and almost what
800 million main lenders whatever that
that number is the other piece that I
wanted to ask is is there any sympathy
for the Hong Kongers within the mainland
is there a nascent I wouldn't call it a
democracy movement and but at least a
freedom freedom of expression movement
or is the government in such firm
control that's a fantasy give me a
picture of where this goes
thank you though I have no answers
because this is an ongoing struggle but
I do want to say that the control state
you've put your finger right on it a
control state is China has built a whole
ecosystem of control through the
technology through the law we didn't
even talk about the cybersecurity long
history of the world and the most
comprehensive because it and also is
built on self-censorship it's also built
on social a host social platforms of the
community reporting on each other so
there's this whole ecosystem which is
pretty comprehensive that feeds each
other but the one thing about technology
that's interesting is that the asymmetry
of power that you could have a very
powerful authoritarian state it has not
been able notwithstanding the the mass
crackdowns on lawyers not with saying
the torture on the mainland not
notwithstanding the killing of until
thousands in 1989 of tanks they have not
the Communist Party has not been able to
shut down people
Chinese people who continue to work for
a whole range of human rights so that's
number one the second thing we haven't
really mentioned is that Hong
Kong has always been since 89 the only
city and I will say within formal China
that has over a hundred thousand people
every year on June 4th remembering it
was Hong Kong students it was Hong Kong
journalists who went up to Beijing to
support the democracy movement and there
are very moving stories of the
protesters knowing that the tanks were
coming they said look the Hong Kong
students they must make it safely back
because they will tell our kin the
Beijing regime tolerate Hong Kong isn't
Hong Kong a fundamental threat to this
whole control regime half of Hong Kong
is the fundamental threat the part of
Hong Kong that can be its golden goose
that lays the golden egg they like that
pot but that goose isn't living in a
free-range farm and they want that
golden goose to absolutely you know be
like keep laying those eggs but you know
you're gonna have no air no this on that
so they're trying to do something
impossible they're trying to keep half
of Hong Kong denying of reality of who
and what Hong Kong is because Hong Kong
MERS have we have had a history of
freedom and we have had a history of
working courts and independence you
can't just wipe it sympathy from
mainlanders
I know because I also teach human rights
seminars at some institutions in Hong
Kong that mainlanders participate in the
kindy demonstrations and I can tell you
when they participate in the
demonstrations in Hong Kong million
people their parents back home on the
mainland will get a knock on the door
and a visit from the public security
saying your daughter your son is in
those marches tell them to stop so the
they're both in Hong Kong mainlanders in
Hong Kong are very it's not just what
you see in the media of them fighting
and protesting and fighting there are
Hong Kongers who support and are
inspired by that's what Beijing is
afraid of they're afraid that's why they
first censored everything and then
suddenly they realize oh my gosh we
can't censor it everybody actually has
the
illegal VPNs and they are getting the
information so then they started doing
the disinformation because the silent
you know The Blackout didn't work so
they started the disinformation the
other point is that there are
mainlanders from the beginning in june
who have expressed support for the hong
kong democracy movement online what has
happened to them arrested detained
threatened intimidated etc so
notwithstanding the full force of an
authoritarian police state they're not
able to shut it down and mr. king
they're not able to tell mainlanders who
do see what they're seeing and who are
not afraid and are willing to also pay
the price to support hong kong's
movement because they understand that if
hong kongers can hold the line then the
mainlanders who also want democracy and
freedom can also have a chance but hong
kongers are the front line well i want
to join my colleagues in thanking you
all it's hard for us to conceive of the
courage that it takes there's no doubt
that in this room today is someone
reporting to Beijing about each of your
testimony that's right and please make
sure we're stated properly I don't want
any misquote and and and I want to thank
you for your courage to speak the truth
and hopefully we will be able to pass
some of this legislation to to make it
clear to the to the regime in Beijing
that democracy is an important value and
that we're just not going to pay lip
service to it thank you all very much
thank you miss thank you very much
senator Danes Thank You mr. chairman
I want to thank this panel for coming
for his commission providing some
perspective expertise on this important
and very timely topic as many of you
know I spent more than five years living
in Guangzhou and part of that time in
Hong Kong back in the 1990s when I was
in the private sector raising a family
in fact we have four children our two
youngest children both born in Hong Kong
I'm deeply concerned with the ongoing
erosion of autonomy and human rights in
the region and I will tell you I stand
with the citizens of Hong Kong
in fact just this past month I helped
lead a legislative exchange between the
US and six legio leaders who came to my
home state of Montana this event was
important to better understand the
situation in Hong Kong and in
identifying what some of the key issues
were and have a very open and free
exchange as leader the free world we the
United States and the entire world must
continue to support the autonomy and the
freedoms of Hong Kong it is one country
two systems'
I was in Hong Kong on June 30th 1997 and
saw the Union Jack come down for the
last time the Hong Kong central
government needs to work with protestors
to accept the demands put for by the
citizens of the country and the use of
excessive force by the police must end
immediately we must continue to work
together towards building a strong
relationship between our two countries a
question I'll start with mr. Wong the
protesters have formed a consensus
around five demands including withdrawal
of the extradition bill and of course
universal suffrage does the government
need to comply with all five demands
immediately or is there a phase or
alternative outcome that might be
acceptable Hong Kong people fight for
free in action and universal suffrage
since free that case ago even earlier
than I born or the five two months is
the consensus of Hong Kong is talk to
the street in the past three months and
all those five two months are also
within the existing constitutional
framework especially Beijing make the
promise in the sino-british joint
declaration and recognise the importance
to let Hong Kong people enjoy freedom
and autonomy especially with the quote
of Hong Kong people ruling Hong Kong so
I would say that democracy movement and
protests must continue and the other day
we have democracy even we strongly
experienced the state capitalist regime
down on Hong Kong human right so I would
say that now we have continued our
summer of this content and becoming the
year of this content we just hope the
world to understand more how Hong Kong
people we're in the difficult time in
this long term an uphill battle let me
if I could enjoy thank you I've got a
vote coming I've got to get to a problem
to get there quickly but I filed
question how do you expect chief
executive Carrie Lam how do you think
she'll respond to these demands and how
much power does she have to make
concessions or would Beijing have the
final say that's an extremely good
crusher Carrie Lam is a puppet
government hand-picked by Beijing and
she is not a decision-maker what we
realized is withdraw the bill or not
stopping police brutality or not or let
allow or allowing harm people and your
free election or not all depends on
Beijing authorities instead of chief
executive of Hong Kong Carol M doesn't
have a say on it she's just following
the order from Beijing authorities
especially on how the State Council in
Beijing regularly hold the press
conference in the past few weeks to
criticize on Hong Kong protests it's
already show that how km can solve the
political crisis by her personal
capacity all right thank you I've got to
get I'd love to keep the discussion
going longer but I've got to go down we
appreciate it thank you very much yes so
much and I think mr. Smith one
additional question thank you very much
Jim I'd appreciate it if I could and
Miss haami you did mention it so and I
think it's there's a little further
scrutiny one of the notions of there's
no such thing as a free lunch in my
opinion applies with on steroids to the
issue of Confucius centers which are
just agents of influence pushing the
Beijing line in the past in both my
Subcommittee on Human Rights which I
chaired and this Commission I failed a
series of hearings on Confucius centers
as well as on those entities
universities colleges that get access to
the mainland China especially
and get an enormous number of perks
money physical plant venues for their
colleges or universities including NYU
and matter of fact I had the Chancellor
of NYU testify one of my hearings and
asked that I could go didn't speak and
he allowed me to come and give a speech
or a lecture on human rights in in
Shanghai and the NYU campus but the
concern is that they're enroute to a
thousand or something like that globally
that is to say the Chinese government
with these Confucius centers we have 96
in the United States 82 or public 14 are
private one of the things that I'm most
concerned about and Rob Portman and I
asked for a GAO report on this that
finally came out in February of this
year and that is look at the terms and
conditions which really is mostly secret
but we have a situation where
hand-picked teachers come to the United
States come to Africa go to Africa I
should say Latin America everywhere and
they seemingly are doing education in
the language and culture but it's all
about the worldview and the domestic
defense of cheating things policies
including Hong Kong my question very
specifically is what are the Confucius
centers you have any insights as to what
they're saying about what's going on in
Hong Kong right now and those
universities and colleges us-based that
are in China and today what are they
able to say and do without fear of
retaliation like at the NYU campus in
Shanghai about this great Human Rights
pro-democracy effort on the part of all
of you in Hong Kong
[Music]
start off the Thank You I I think it's
important also to note that the
Confucius Institutes and the push backs
have also been led by really active
wonderful activism by students for free
Tibet and the Tibetan community
supported by the wiggers and I think
they've had some really good victories
that show you really can push back and
get the institutions to be more
accountable and and reliable I think I
think the the quick answer to what are
they saying
it's what can they say will always be
under the guideline right now under the
the now the ideological campaign that's
underway where every single Party
non-member has to participate in
political study that the line of the day
what can be reported in Xinhua what can
be reported in the news everything will
be determined from the top and you if
you say anything and as you know under
the new regulations under the
cybersecurity act for the news news is
defined very broadly to include opinion
in a commentary including blogging
including it so you can't say blog think
anything except what the line comes down
so when the line comes down in Hong Kong
currently the line is it is a riot
backed up by black hands led by the u.s.
interfering in domestic an affair and
and violating China's sovereignty this
is the same ol chestnut you you know we
all hear over and over and they got to
get a better story here but that's what
they keep saying and so I think that is
now the dominant what work what anyone
can say because if you say anything
against that for example you have a
different idea not only are you
violating the new news regulations
you're also running the risk of
subversion incitement because that is
defined as you know going against the
party's view so I think that's why it is
so important that the that the
authoritarian system in the mainland
must change it's got to change or I
think it's still you know I think that
Hong Kong people I know I've heard some
of my my friends and colleagues say to
the u.s. bleed
save us I had to have another angle on
that I think Hong Kong people will save
ourselves
I think Hong Kong people are going to do
it what I think is necessary from the
international community is please help
make the human cost less because it's
very clear and heartbreaking that the
young people are ready to go to the mat
and I think the key is as I think the US
government and this Commission is doing
is to stand by so that the human costs
can be mitigated a little bit understand
but how do the teachers in the Confucius
Institute get their marching orders so I
this is like going inside of a black box
but let me speculate yeah I am pretty
sure that all the curricula are approved
and reviewed I'm pretty sure they don't
exercise academic freedom and say here's
a creative thing I can do about Hong
Kong you know I'm pretty sure that
they're all approved curricula how do we
know this because you will see nothing
there about 89 you will know yeah there
are just big holes in that history
what's happening and all of the you'll
probably read about the diverse ethnic
groups in China happy people happy
Tibetans happy Weaver's you know you
probably see that version of what is
happening so I'm pretty sure the other
thing is if the those institutes are
also monitored so if anyone says
anything that actually challenges the
dominant narrative I'm pretty sure that
teacher will be in trouble so I think
it's pretty tightly controlled and the
money is the what do you see the word
the the the the enticement to
universities and I think not only just
for the Confucius Institutes they
sometimes come along with other really
good goods like an endowed chair like
money for a chair like money for a
program so I think there's this this
kind of collapse
um because senator Gaines left can I say
something to him anyway yes okay I'm so
sorry but I really think it's important
as somebody who loves Hong Kong and and
personally and professionally and as a
member of the from the private sector I
think we
to also remember that every single SOE
state-owned enterprise has a party
committee and now that requirement has
extended to foreign to companies with
foreign investments and foreign
companies
I had a far a Canadian company asked me
how could that be why they making us
establish a party committee I said
you're not being